chaque semaine on voit apparaître de
nouvelles études concernant les
changements climatiques les preuves
scientifiques sur les origines humaines
de ces crises environnementales sont
clairement établies mais malgré ce
consensus il ya des climato-sceptiques
qui continue de recevoir une part
important de l'attention médiatique on
va parler donc à notre connexion avec
renommée ni gayral gagné bonjour non pas
au jeu décortiquer ces dossiers
premièrement faisait malgré les études
malgré les avertissements il ya toujours
des gens qui ne croit pas au changement
climatique mais ça c'est ce qui
s'affirme climato sceptiques c'est à
dire qu'ils refusent de reconnaître
l'existence des changements climatiques
causés par l'activité humaine
malgré toutes les preuves scientifiques
ont acquis montre que c'est vraiment en
train de se passer et il ya eu des
changements quand même dans le discours
de ces personnes au cours des dernières
années il ya une décennie on peut voir
des gens qui n'y est carrément que les
changements climatiques étaient en cours
alors que de nos jours bon voyons que
ces gens-là continue de parler en disant
que oui les changements climatiques
existent mais c'est pas vraiment là pour
des êtres humains et c'est ce qui leur a
permis de continuer ce changement de
discours lot 2 continue d'avoir de
prendre une place beaucoup très
importante en fait dans le discours
public voit il est une étude vous
épancher d'ailleurs sur l'étude qui a
été publiée ce dont on se rend compte
c'est que le disco des
climato-sceptiques est beaucoup plus
présent dans les médias qu'on aurait pu
passer
c'est une étude qui est paru cette
semaine dans la revue nature
communications c'est des chercheurs qui
ont analysé 100 mille articles dans des
médias anglophones faut le dire est
qu'ils ont été publiés entre l'an 2000
et 2016
autant dans des journaux réputés que des
sites internet très populaire et les
chercheurs ont comparé la présence de
300 des scientifiques les plus
importants que n'expire des spécialisés
changements climatiques les plus
importants avec celles de personnalités
de personnes qui sont reconnus pour leur
opposition à cette notion là parmi
lesquels on a des politiciens des
personnalités publiques et aussi des
scientifiques et les chercheurs ont
remarqué que son gala sera publique dans
son ensemble
le disque aux climato-sceptiques une
couverture 50% plus importante que celle
des spécialistes du climat social
impressionne là dedans c'est sûr que yo
des sites internet avec certains blogs
personnels qui sont dont le pion mis de
l'avant
donc si on se concentre davantage sur
les médias traditionnels important on
dans lesquels on trouve par exemple le
new york times the guardian mais aussi
fox news même si ben ici
radio canada anglais mais là on tend
plutôt à une parité entre les climato
sceptiques et c'est les points de vue
des chercheurs qui sont des spécialistes
du climat
à quelle parité mais les arguments
défendus vue ne sont pas équivalents non
c'est ça effectivement pas et les
chercheurs de les spécialistes de
l'étude ont voulu justement voir
l'importance que les médias donnent aux
travaux des scientifiques qu'on retrouve
dans les deux groupes et ils ont marqué
que leur lait dans les bilans leurs
échantillons de scientifiques qu'ils ont
qui reconnaissent les changements
climatiques ces chercheurs ont publié
quatre fois plus d'études et ses
étudiants étaient cités u 8 fois plus
souvent que celles qui ont été mises de
l'avant par des scientifiques qui se
disent sceptiques
mais malgré ce nombre beaucoup plus
important d'études crédit qui est
produite par les spécialistes du climat
quand on passe à la sphère médiatique
mais les travaux des climato-sceptiques
remonte la pente et réussissent à
exciter 50% du temps faut dire que la
base de données que les chercheurs ont
utilisé pour leur étude permet pas de
distinguer si les médias parlent en bien
ou en mal d argument des climato
sceptiques mais simplement mentionné ces
travaux là dans la sphère publique ça
leur donne une visibilité médiatique
beaucoup plus importantes que celles
qu'ils ont réellement dans la sphère
scientifique est ce que les chercheurs
ont une idée des causes de ce
déséquilibre
ils sont peu pencher là-dessus ce que
croit qu'une partie du problème saviez
du souci d'équilibré des journalistes
ont qui est celui de présenter tous les
points de vue dans une histoire qui en
développement ce faut dire que c'est une
façon d'agir est extrêmement importante
le faut le dire en journalisme surtout
pour des événements qui affectent
différents groupes de façon différente
ou quand on parle de politique mais
quand on arrive en sciences une façon un
peu plus plus une semaine un peu plus de
problèmes parce que un consensus
scientifique c'est pas une série
d'opinion qui s'opposent aussi quelque
chose qui doit vraiment être établi sur
des données mesurées et c'est sûr que
quand une nouvelle étude publiée il va y
avoir des débats il va y avoir des
arguments mais éventuellement les
données de ces étudiants vont finir on
finir par être répétée par d'autres
chercheurs confirmés par d'autres
groupes avec les années qui passent
alors que les élites étude dont les
données sont pas confirmées ou pas
répéter vont finir par sombrer dans
l'oubli
alors si on vient au changement
climatique quand on veut balancer cette
histoire avec un pot et en contre on
finit souvent par donner une visibilité
exagérait des sources dont l'opinion est
marginale dans la communauté
scientifique est en terminale ce
discours qu'on a atteint 2
aura plus des climato-sceptiques 56 a
fini par rentrer dans la tête des gens
les gens avec le public par exemple si
ce sablier qui va augmenter l'importance
des climato sceptiques dans l'est dans
l'oeil du public parce que au lieu de
voir qu'ils vont voir que pas de
consensus ils vont devoir y auront
l'impression que plusieurs cas à l'écran
alors qu'au niveau de la science c'est
pas le cas par contre ce genre de choses
ça peut vraiment les jouer dans ces
histoires le peuvent aller jouer dans le
cerveau des personnes
ça peut aller jouer sur certains
mécanismes qui ont favorisé la
propagation des idées des
climato-sceptiques par exemple on a tout
ce qu'on appelle lé biais de
confirmation se sait quand on va
toujours préféré une information qui va
conforter nos opinions plutôt qu'une
information qui va venir nous remettre
en question
c'est aussi par exemple une histoire où
il ya beaucoup de questions d'identité
qui vient jouer l'adq il y joue là
dessus c'est un sujet les changements
climatiques est très politisée qui est
très polarisée aussi qu'ils ont été ou
dans certains endroits dans la
population et notre cerveau a toujours
tendance à accepter
l'opinion du groupe auquel on serait
lyon ceux auxquels on se rattache le
plus donc discuter de ces idées-là de la
façon dont on parle en ce moment mais
c'était une love vient montrer que ça
peut être une partie du problème et ça
vient ça peut être une des raisons pour
lesquelles on est en difficulté à
trouver une solution au problème du
changement climatique une étude qui va
faire réagir
assurément merci c'est pourquoi non
merci